[Music]
hi hello am i alive hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
we happy few how are you doing everybody
welcome so much to hear and how we're
gonna be playing this game so I know
it's been a while since I played this
game I know I've been super busy with
other stuff and I'm leaving for Korea in
in a week now so I've got a lot of stuff
on my plate and I know that this game is
also very long so I haven't exactly
gotten much progress in the game so I'm
hoping that in this stream right here
when I play it right now I'm able to
blast through a lot of this stuff
without going back all the time trying
to fix everything to be nuanced about it
what it is is what it is like it is what
it is and what I do is what I do and if
I just so happen to screw up and throw a
old lady into a tree then so be it
that's what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
give it a little bit of time for people
to get in here and I just wanted to say
thank you so much for joining me on this
lovely lovely adventure into we happy
few I don't know when or if I'll ever be
able to finish this game but I
definitely didn't want to leave it where
I was leaving it so we're gonna get into
it and it's gonna be good maybe I don't
know how do you become a member you hit
the join button right down there below
or there's a link in the description or
there should be anyway probably wait oh
no this is video look okay to you
did I screw up a setting somehow I don't
think I did oh I did now whatever it
should be okay no matter what it just to
be a little bit off yeah it's probably
fine it's probably fine I'm not gonna
worry about it too much worrying about
things makes you not happy and this game
is all about being happy so let's go for
it getting back into it now this should
be the most recent save which should be
the one where the old lady's in the tree
so I don't think I need to go back and
see if that old lady is indeed in the
tree but you know I'm just going to go
about my day no matter what and if
things go horribly wrong later on then
oops
oopsy poopsy I played this to be as
happy as I could play it and that's
actually how I'm going to go about it go
oh there's a cutting time stick so long
have no idea
mark Blair who's darker plier I don't
know some guy some dude maybe me I don't
know don't hug me I'm scared is coming
back what does that even mean oh yeah
just rest in the fleet thank you Michael
oh just resting my feet huh is this oh
it's right outside of them it's right
outside of the locale she's still off
well there she is um so uh anyway
toodaloo I've got other stuff to do I
got to go to the house of the Interior
so um let's see House of the Interior is
where is that I don't know where that is
where's the house the interior maybe I
gotta track that no no that's tract ah
um ah um BA Oh up there okay so I got to
go up there wherever that is however I
get to there lalala don't mind me is it
still curfew probably not right oh oh
there's curfew sorry just went through
that gasps don't mind me excuse me
everybody I just got to go over here for
a lot of time and you got to stop doing
whatever you gotta do yeah
I'm pretty good thanks for asking
I'm pretty good thank you was this game
about sorry I was reading chat not
looking at where I was going
this game is about being happy that's
all it is about what do you got it what
are you gonna know anything else about
its 648 am I just like to go jogging for
an early morning get go
whatever that means I like to start my
day off right with a happy little jog no
no no trouble no trouble no trouble no
trouble hey hey listen hey buddy you
wouldn't turn a blind eye to me okay
they're mad at me
so I got to go hide in the woods for a
little bit and let them forget about who
and where and who I was don't mind me
look body body body listen I'm super
Sneaky you wouldn't know where I was
would you yeah you wouldn't now you
through stupid to figure it out yeah
where did I leave off okay so we left
off in the house of smacking pleasure
which was a lovely place to be to be
perfectly honest it was really nice very
1'p all that kind of stuff like that and
yeah it was uh pretty good am i okay in
life oh geez well thank you so much for
that lucid who's the plague thank you
Mark for everything you do I haven't
been able to support you before but I
can now looking forward to the next
charity livestreams and continue to be
awesome well you don't need to you don't
need to do that you don't need to you
don't need to do that at all like not at
all don't don't even worry about that
don't even bother with that yeah that's
a lot of people watching
I'm surprised considering Lee
[Music]
oh that's you jack okay hello I'm joking
I had a fantastic night's sleep actually
that's how I like it how about you if
you were taking your joy then you
shouldn't have any trouble sleeping well
what are you waiting for
get back on your dose I think I could
promise you your day will go as a sweet
breeze okay all right sweeties are some
breeze you say well sweet is whatever
this guy's gonna say that's the one who
done it
I saw one excuse me they know to check
up on dr. Faraday wheeze Bobby
Higginbotham the executive committee
don't let just anyone drop by the lab
you know not because they might be
friends who talked to Rick you know what
doctor if could do with a bucket of
mytilene and a handful of mechanical
boots no I don't either and that's the
point in it he's at the Reform club
again what are you implying
apparently he feels a bit guilty about
dr. if you don't know about his sir oh
sure but we Hickenbottom is marrying my
sister and I will thank you not to cast
any aspersions mutation I have been
ordered by the general himself to ask
for credentials from the Beautification
Committee have you got any there you go
Oh fine we'll chat for anyone shattering
away in something that don't sound like
English you like married dogs and
they'll give you a plague and keep your
mouth shut about paint chunks right oh
you better take these in case you do
catch plague over there not that I would
we Wow really you're just kind of a
douche ain't you well Thank You
Sebastian hey Mark hope you're doing
well I'm donating because I know there
are a lot of people in the world that
needs the money I've been sub well I
want to be very clear the super chat
that's not for a charity stream I'm
gonna turn off the notifications for
that because I don't want anyone
misconstruing that's not going to
charity that's why I say you don't need
to do anything
this isn't for charity there that's just
for nothing so I'm actually going to
just
give me a second ah da da da da da da
everyone to entertain yourselves play a
little game in chat tell me what your
favorite sport is what do you win what
do you like to count points in what do
you like to play when you go and recess
yeah one second hang on hang on a second
hang on uh delay dated order date adobo
boba and all but hop HAP huh
but it there we go all right soon as it
clears out everything that it's got in
the queue for that and let me also do
one more thing so it's not too terribly
obtrusive and breaking the loveliness of
the environment that we're in yeah I
appreciate all the the desire to support
I really do honestly I truly do but like
I've said before I super chats don't eat
it don't eat it at all don't need it
thank you so much for that if you want
to get something join the join the
channel through the membership program
you get cool stuff for it I've got more
cool stuff planned in the future and
it'll be good hey sorry about talking
about your future brother-in-law here's
some scotch
Oh God
same thing oh really well if you want to
be touched more go to the house of
reputable delights or whatever it is all
right what do we have over here
I like button that's why they
quarantined all the wastrels with plague
isn't it
that's a cheery thought why is that one
glowing like that why is that why are
you glowing like that why you why are
you glowing why you he said he hadn't
got a scratch I'd call those wrenches
wouldn't you are you sure it's safe to
get that close you won't catch it from
looking there could be spores try not to
get bitten they go too crazy towards the
end
thanks I'll be careful I got a rubber
suit
wind up like him what Oh doesn't go for
me when he does oh all right well I'll
take care of this one oh sorry sorry
listen sorry I just needed to handle you
can we work something up let me take
your possibly infected stuff all right I
gotta go whomp some people who needs a
hug Scott strong desire for one P no no
no but oh oh oh wait whoa Jesse sit the
cat suit what's the deal what's the deal
James can't a guy have a little little
simple pleasures in life so I like to be
prodded so I like to be shocked
tantalizing on my nip knobs that doesn't
mean that you need to judge me can I add
in his bouche no and you had for a
second there is this where I was before
is this where like the is this like the
where the wastrels were before I'm not
on represent your yeah probably maybe no
I guess I've never been here before I
think that was the air no that was the
military camp then where was I when I
went into the was it here
yeah maybe okay I've got a long way to
go but I got to follow the road ruined
house there let me just go straight to
the destination because I don't have
time to waste around if I want any
chance of beating this game hey buddy
don't mind me in my rubber suit it's a
real nice suits got a good look to it
you know hey listen buddy listen listen
friend you wouldn't hit a guy with a
rubber suit would you I mean you might
and I might like it but that's besides
the point
listen I don't want to make any trouble
for nobody okay I probably need to make
more of those Healy bits because I seem
to be doing badly for the Healy bits no
how do I I only have that so I need to
actually craft up some healing balm okay
Rose of Gilead that's the stuff that I
jumped off a mountain for but that did
not go well for me there we go just
splash that is just tuck it inside my
rubber suit it'll it'll smoosh out
everywhere yeah NTX thanks for inspiring
me to be Who I am today this is uh both
that's that this is really all I have
for you then don't give me anything
don't seriously don't give me anything I
don't need it it's not a give it to
someone who actually does need it
or better yet keep it for yourself buy
yourself something nice like that's
that's what you should do if there's
anyone in the world that doesn't need
that it's probably me did I finish those
pretzels you know I didn't but I'm gonna
I'm gonna actually uh I'm gonna hold off
on getting them for now
I got tea with this help me thirsty okay
well that's good all right
what happened to subnautica I beat the
game I've really gone what do you want
to order like dr. Farrah died they must
be extremely dangerous yeah
[Music]
okay all right well then lover's quarrel
hey how you doing hey hey listen hey
buddy are you who I need to talk to hey
buddy you don't mind if I just pop on in
do you because that's what I do
the professor's gonna kill us she's
gonna tell them to send us away
I'm always mucking things up for her
lodges worse he breaks everything is
gonna send us both away can you get us a
new vowel I'd let you use the
professor's lab oh it's brilliant dr.
Faraday's a woman you sexist piece of
[ __ ] boys yeah also James I am a
stranger I came up out of the brush I'm
wearing a rubber suit filled with some
weird balm I made from flowers I found
at night you probably shouldn't trust me
with the ability to use the professor's
lab equipment oh well whatever I'll find
you gosh-darned valve then oh wow you
are more than pathetic than I thought
you were here you go buddy
there you go this is for you good pal
can I get a hug from the professor and
help from Roger all right whatever
whatever you say man okay well take your
joy thank you
I'll go in then I guess I'm in
what was that what was that stop did you
see did you try did you almost say stop
[ __ ] the dog cuz that's I have many
questions okay I don't have either of
these but dirty bandage oh boy
dirty bandage oh that that's stops
bleeding casco can cause infection okay
yeah okay all right okay flushes all the
joy from your body why on earth would
you want to do that zeros out joy level
does not reduce withdrawal or memory
loss symptoms okay whatever you say all
right something tells me dr. Faraday is
this going to be a peach all right let
me pick this lock I guess I don't know I
don't even know why this is my objective
I was just here to talk to this person
in you Oh Roger love James ah that's so
sweet
well I got Rick the stunned duck oh
that's not killing me it seems like this
might kill me oh I should probably just
sitting here breathing in this
mysterious green gas ah much better okay
oh this is not a dance hall this isn't
this is not a dance pole then what uh
what what is it for then miss Faraday
what what uh what um what is this for
can I use oh man there's no cutscene
where you can use that
oh you like my rubber suit I bet you do
it's full of mom all right
oh don't mind me I'm gonna take all of
this all right okay
so there's something there if that's a
trap for some reason this place is full
trips I let me just sprint through here
real quick
no thank you I guess
hello oh oh memory why do I have a
memory here weighs this where I have a
memory because it's 1946 and the wrongs
left Britain in 450 ad Wow
I can't hear you what do you want this
big Latin you always you always you
always know you always know you always
know you always know there's no what
each always know what each word means
and it comes out impedimenta the baggage
impediment orem of the baggage and
impediment is to for baggage doesn't
matter you say things yes so long as the
docking about package what
no I'm talking about oh [ __ ] off why are
you learning Lots in any way you'd still
have trouble in English I can see it in
my head you make the words face sticking
endings on them well that seems like an
awful lot of effort when you learn
German when when you learned you when
you I don't want to learn German you
just have to stick the right ending on
to the word I don't want to learn
it's very good language it has very
strict rules a much a more surprise huh
that's fascinating
cuz koreans kind of the same way it's a
lot about what's coming on the end of
each word that basically changes up how
it how it is you know you can change
like and to from like all from just the
endings of the words so sorry no no no
no no no listen listen please and what
is this Leeson huh please take detailed
notes on dr. Faraday's mood and behavior
irritable irritable contemptuous bad
peevish flew into a rage carousing
pacing someone's not taking their joy
do not disturb dr. Faraday authorized
personnel only hello dr. Faraday Faraday
doc oh no no I these chaps they're
trying to open the bridge distant George
what do you mean you you locked in what
did you do the executive committee I
wasn't going to make any more bankers or
gates or cable ups or keepers or to
Bellator's oh I can do that well no I
don't work for them will you let me out
oh I don't suppose you see a large red
button on that side that says there is a
button but it doesn't say that they
don't trust those boys out there can't
say I blame them I can't trust them not
to set themselves on fire all right
maybe you can still help me no sort of
hoping you could tell me how to fix the
bridge dissin George huh but not to here
so I'll need a few things from you
oh no oh sure brilliant I need a bucket
full of mentally according to the
pressure
children there's air in the pipes here
God usually means Elise here take this
vacuum you can keep afterwards I don't
plan to Bienvenue here Wow a vacuum I
don't see how a vacuum is gonna help me
how's a Swiffer gonna help me Bowl it
blow up the cage that you're in I have a
funny feeling that I'm gonna somehow
cause you to meet your untimely demise
Oh get a bucket of modeling oh just that
easy huh um
metal bits duct tape um is there
something over there no I'm out oh there
was a chest got it nope okay so where am
I going to get mo to lean what am i
picking what am i picking here I have no
idea yeah that's one big button yeah you
know they don't want anyone messing up
on anything over here they want people
definitely to get the buttons when they
got the buttons okay so is modeling like
nearby do I got a dig for modeling what
is modeling by the way what's modeling
let's see uh modeling the pow oh wait mo
d'Alene's that purple stuff that's what
the vacuums for I gotta suck it out ah
all right I'll upgrade myself later Han
how do i where's where's that vacuum
that's not a vacuum that's not a vacuum
either that
where'd that vacuum didn't I didn't I
just get a vacuum where the vacuum go
awesome full of crap okay all right
okay all right okay maybe I wasn't
paying attention there and I'm just a
big dumb doof but I have no idea where
it gets mortal did they tell me today is
that the Faraday wait oh okay all right
I'm on it I'm on it I'm in it I'm in it
to win it I know what I'm doing that's
reckless you didn't have to make my
choices if you didn't want to do that
change you know probably when the whole
government takeover thing happened and
where my gas mask you say I don't know
what you're talking about
but there's modally and over here my
nose is telling me that if I sprint
straight in this direction for as long
as I need to
I'm gonna find some purple stuff and I'm
gonna get some purple stuff and then I'm
it's gonna be good yeah I need to play
the subnautica DLC I will but it's not
out yet so I don't think it's gonna come
out for a while they only just announced
it so I mean probably not anyway maybe
I'm wrong I'm probably wrong but you
know I'm never wrong about much of
anything but this one I'm really admit
that I might not be yeah do the science
thing hey you know I got half a degree
in doing science thing whoo I saw God I
saw I saw the other side on young maku
hi Marc hello thank you
I saw something anyway all right let's
keep moving I guess Rowen Barry I don't
know if Rowan Barry's actually any good
for me still only at half health half
health but I need to find more materials
doings crafted can I slurp from this I
guess not
it's not like Skyrim where I can just
gather everything and anything in the
nearby area and just hope that it
combines in some way or shape or form
what what are you what do you think you
are judging me how I'm dressed just
digging through trash cans looking for
Moda lien you sent in a purple stuff you
got some purple drink
no oh
he can't see me I'm so stealthy in my
suit no excuse me no no what is this
drunk no nothing Moda lean god it's so
far away places so far but I gotta oh my
god it's so far what the what the hell
that's so far all right whatever I guess
I'll just keep running and I guess I can
shut up half degrees count
sadly half degrees do not count it's not
I wish I wish that's how it was like
when you got your degree out of college
you just like for each course and credit
hour that you complete it just prints
out just a little bit more of your
degree and so you can be like oh I have
half a degree just doesn't have the
deans signature on it but it looks
pretty good
please stop dumping chemicals you'll
kill the fish
um no die no diving
no diving are you kidding me Oh scotch
oh that's probably still good nothing
cheese up a bowl be like a nice bottle
of scotch yeah true dad hey how you
doing buddy you wouldn't happen to have
an antiseptic bandage would you make how
are you alive what is wrong with you
someone serve a whole bunch of medical
supplies all around here I think I must
have stepped on an infected needle would
you help me clean it all up before
someone else gets sick if I stick my
fingers in that pond why not get
infected too
well it's not gonna clean itself up that
looks awfully unhealthy now I'm not sure
I'd enjoy getting stuck with one of
those needles Oh
what are you doing why are you you take
it take them down I think I buy I think
I probably should just considering uh
where I am how I'm in the pond take that
I guess I'll take that dirty bandits
empty syringe YUM this is a weirdest
side quest I've ever seen oh god I'm I
wonder why why am i dying we rub some
ointment on this ah that really took
care of that poison nothing like a good
point man let me clean this up a lot of
good
whoa taking a shower get it in my
eyeballs la la la I see new colors I
guess I'm out of here
you know just for good measure don't
struggle it's fine it's fine let me get
you out of here buddy I'm gonna get you
out of here I'm gonna get you out here
here you do you know this man he's
probably infected
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry that was just too
funny for me oh no do I prefer funny or
scary I've funny thinking but it's so
hard to get speak this is like real
funny yeah most the time you just have
to make your own funny out of it
dressed like a normal person excuse you
don't can't shame me I am proud of Who I
am
bees they can't sting me through my
rubber suit oh I'm gonna get this couch
okay maybe I'm not gonna get that that's
probably bad man they really don't like
me oh man I am not doing any sort of
good look at this is what happens when
like you you put the objective too far
away
I just get I get super offshore and let
me rub some ointment on those bee wounds
ah those stings really do get ya through
the suit oh well I guess some people
think all right why is it so far away
where am I now
where am I God good God cleanse the
doors of your perception you it's me I'm
real [ __ ] up man oh my god I'm such a
good time oh boy oh boy
oh boy ma that real pissed off of me I
don't know what I did I just knocked a
few people unconscious
I'm real hungry you guys can I eat this
rubber duck what can I eat here pretty
bread ice and bread nothing like some
road bread now let me rub some ointment
on my my wounds and we're good to go all
right
hey listen listen listen you can't see
me in the yellow bush where did I go I'm
like a shadow in the night no one can
fight no one no one no one no one can
find me if they found me I'm stuck they
found me I don't know how Shh it's okay
okay just lie down ow hey what are you
doing it's fine
shotgun ow sorry sorry to bother you
listen to all my me I don't know where
I'm going where is this guy oh it's in
the oh it's in the city that makes a lot
of sense I don't I did what
why listen guys you don't I'm in a
catsuit how could you see yellow bushes
they can't see me there's no way I'm -
oh so I forget which flowers are the
ones that like actually mask me there's
there's like some flowers but I don't
think these are them Oh God
the killer I didn't kill anybody I just
squeezed some people's larynxes oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god can I make anymore what about an old
bandage can I make a [ __ ] bandage can I
[ __ ] on a bandage no again I can't make
anything anyway all right what if I got
dirty bandage that'll do put it on no I
can't fly I don't need to use this never
mind I'm gonna run this way
goodbye goodbye everybody oh sorry I'd
way too much fun with that one all right
I'm gonna go for it this time I guess
I'll take off my suit but I don't want
to I don't want to where am i how far
away oh how did I manage to crawl back
here I you know honestly I don't even
know anymore but it's so far away oh boo
I'm not gonna be able to get in there
with my sister like this mi I wish I
could but I I don't want to take it off
yeah
what's the last of us - trailer I've
already seen it it's good and I'll
probably play the game when it comes up
take the suit off I don't know what do
you guys think I'll leave it up to you
do you guys think I should take the suit
off we'll leave it on off on off on on
off what do you guys think off take it
off take off the damn suit take it off
take all clothes off
keep it on take it off leave it on off
I'm seeing a lotta off all right well
the the vote is off so off all right I
took it off we're good to go they should
accept me now I assuming this is a
colony of nudists anyway so if I if I
knew like I can usually spot a fetish
from a mile away and then I guess I
misjudged them on the catsuit thing but
I think I think this is gonna be perfect
that's nice
[Music]
am i wearing pants hey don't
oh you yell at me when I have clothes
you yell at me when I don't have clothes
like what's your deal guys take this oh
oh I guess oh wait don't mind me I'm
just hang on wait listen legend this
isn't what it looks like I swear clever
scuse me sir what what did I do what
what why am i dying wait why my day oh
wait is it poison in here oh [ __ ] it is
isn't it
oh well [ __ ] [ __ ] oh it's I'm dying cuz
it's poisonous in here
well [ __ ] [ __ ] uh I don't know what to
do and I don't have wait no I can craft
hang on I can craft I did pick up more
of those I picked up a bunch of those oh
yeah get those I'll get those yeah I'll
get those I just need to rub ointment on
my nude body that's what I need to do
okay okay just rub some ointment on me
right on the nips oh yeah on the
especially on the nips
okay got those we're good to go oh yeah
this looks good this place looks great
okay
here we go
I got some great pranks
hmm I don't know if I have any power
cells but good point I guess I don't
know oh if I
she's look gonna let me keep it so
that's good okay all right good okay
good all right so I need to get out of
here before I die I'm dying
it turns out that I'm dying but good
thing I got what I didn't I didn't do
that oh why did that happen this is the
game was just like mark you need to stop
this is just freaking embarrassing at
this point just seriously you need to
stop immediately like there's there's no
point to anything that you're doing
you're an embarrassment to the entire
Internet and everybody that actually
enjoys this game oh there's a lot of
people out there and I gotta rub some
ointment on me listen hang on you watch
you're gonna watch you're gonna watch me
put this ointment on oh did you like
that oh you didn't like it
he didn't like it he didn't like it he
didn't like it he didn't like it he
didn't like it much nothing much not at
all he didn't like it yeah oh you guys
are just mean why won't you let me be me
rubbing ointment on my nude body
whenever and wherever I want you're
you're you're just all a bunch of bigots
you all are haters you mean awful don't
let me be me oh well you know I can only
hope for so much with these people
they're kink shamers yeah they are they
are they are king shamers nude is where
it's at everyone knows this you have to
be nude to appreciate the finer details
of life you see all these sharp blades
of grass grazing against my taint that's
what life's all about
ah the free that's what I'm sorry I said
that I apologize profusely I apologize
profusely for giving everyone that image
yeah anyway carry as if nothing happened
I better make more goop just gonna make
more Healy goop
nobody mind me there we go and plenty of
goop there we go I don't need to heal up
anymore I'm maximum Lee [ __ ] but once
this goop rubs off I'll be pooping back
up in no time I need to take this more
seriously but I've got a long run and
then my mind just kind of wanders as I
go yeah the cops in the game are stupid
I don't think they're stupid I think
they're just indecisive of whether or
not to chase the naked man rubbing
ointment all over his body he goes just
like randomly screaming with his cricket
bat oh boy that's funny this is a very
serious game I can tell and I am doing
it no sir I'm really doing it a very
clear disservice here what is the point
of the cars but boy no idea all right
let me just get on where I was we get on
hey there's nothing in this well what is
this game you know this is we happy few
look at my dick look at it look at my
dick look at it
I swear my dicks not made of plywood and
paper mache how dare you that's such an
insult it's the real deal down there
it's not just it's not just paper mache
you dick you dick what a dick talking
about my dick like that do I like this
game I do I do
and I'm really sorry that I haven't been
playing it you know as I should have
which is like in a timely manner but
whenever it comes to let's plays like
this I always scatter him all over the
place but I have been better about
getting like the longer videos going
when I want to like finish a full game
like donut County that was a great game
I'm so glad I was able to just like play
that in one go put up a video it's super
fun love that one look at my dick anyway
look at my asses I run away you only a
rub ointment on it as I go oh I gotta
cut through another town oh no there's
there's no town here it's just like this
is where she is but for some reason
she's locked up in her own Tower there
[ __ ] did did I did I just take a dump on
the run I guess that's the benefit of
having no clothes on you can just go to
this is for the benefit of mr. kite the
rabbit got into the garden the rabbit
got into the garden sounds like some
sort of secret message okay where's
weird hmm I don't know what the rabbit
in the garden means but mr. kite if I
ever find you I guess I'll tell you
maybe but probably not
hey hey lady I got the goop and I've got
more goop if you want some extra goop
I've got goop for you don't mind me sir
no no why would I do that
hello hi
I would look at that longer but I have
to go I have an appointment I have an
appointment
hello I have some goop would you like
goop its goop delivery knock-knock
goop is that a pole is that a pole
dancing why was there a teddy bear on
that pole miss Faraday don't think I
didn't see that teddy bear on that pole
okay miss paradise are you doing don't
just saunter over here yes sir okay what
you spent science class mooning after a
girl did you have a device that makes a
portal of some kind I just need a few
particular mechanical pieces that's how
I'm getting out how are you getting out
Oh simple really I just need to get to
some George get a letter of transit go
to the parade and cross the Brittania
bridge without being arrested or shot
full of joy by a doctor excellent you'll
need this device I marked the cars that
have the parts in need well off with you
oh okay thank you I guess but also
docile I all right I guess we're done
here
what people on you a little more I see
that I see it I see it I see what you
got going on there I saw that
anyway the extractor is this something
that goes on my head is this a hat this
is a hat isn't it you gave me a hat hey
look a gas mask
but the extractor it looked like a hat
I'm guessing it's a hat
where'd it go hmm where'd it go I
thought it I saw it oh I saw it all
right where was it it was here could
sworn I saw it oh there's no that's not
a hat now that looks like it's something
to pull out pull pull pull my intestines
inside out um I could try wearing it on
my head man whatever all right so I got
that now I need to go again that's what
the cars were for I was you're asking
what they're for and it told me what
they were for oh that makes sense okay
so I need to go get that again oh excuse
me I need to extract this the killer I
didn't kill I didn't kill nobody
excuse you you ran off into the night
with nothing and now you're some sort of
brilliant chemist
how did you survive I wish I could have
helped you
it'd be nice to be friends again instead
of all those dreadful things what what
are you talking about is this really the
time this is like running through the
forest naked just like pontificating
about how he just having a shower
conversation she's running naked through
the woods being chased I didn't kill
anybody by the way actually I killed a
lot of people but I didn't kill the
people that you thought I killed I
killed some people but they probably
weren't too terribly important maybe you
know whatever I know I got to go so far
for this stupid car
can I play more SCP containment breach
SCP is on the way don't worry about it
and there's some good good stuff in
there some goods
in there you guys are gonna like it well
why's it got to be in the middle of town
no no it's not in the middle of town
that's on that hill it's by the bath is
that the bath no that's not the bath
listen don't that's where I parked it no
no no no no hey what are you what are
you doing what are you what are you
doing coming for a closer look
you're weird what do you what no no I
didn't eat my dog I didn't what is wrong
with you
can't a guy be naked can't oh hey this
is a bunch of baloney
look I'm just a simple nudist trying to
make ends meet and you guys are making
my life difficult I just want that car
or I'm in a bush there's no way they can
see me right
there's no way okay I'm gonna get that
bush I'm gonna get that bush get that
bush I'm gonna change this world these
goddamn King shamers they're not gonna
get to me I'm gonna be me and you guys
aren't gonna stop me from being me I'm
the me ask me that ever was me all right
that's right yeah you all you all saw it
off huh you guys told me to take my
clothes off you're the ones that said I
needed to take it off now you're telling
me that I need to put it back on
you guys listen you guys just you
sending me a lot of mixed signals here
I'm just trying to do what I gotta do to
survive you guys are the ones messing
with me
oh dear
this is fine don't worry about it
everything's fine how did I get it
Oh what dude you know you gotta look at
me rub ointment on me out here I'm gonna
rub ointment on me let me rub ointment
on me please there we go
ah L'Amour ointment you have Wow this
guy's really tough oh come on man
there we go wait wait wait I need a
bandage there we go oh yeah oh yeah I
covered it up with bandage you have you
happy and I should have I had that
extracted that was a bunch of baloney ah
fine
you stupid pieces of poop if it's that
important to you
the putting it back on how's that
they're good Oh what the hell I'm gonna
whop the [ __ ] out of you you want to
talk about murder huh I'll mess you up
I'll mess you up I'll mess you up I will
I'll do it Wow I blocked that huh okay
they're pretty tough let me extract oh
no oh no it's not gonna work I'm gonna
die they're gonna kill me
no there I go oh this is so ridiculous I
thought we were living in 2018 where
someone could be naked whatever they
wanted to be naked and then I put
clothes back on and you didn't stop
trying to murder me since when was being
naked of murder all offense thank you
was c-s fruitloop McGee Wow however you
say that still alive wonderific gods
helping me what you're smoking me I
don't know what's what anymore but I'm
gonna get this I hope this isn't too
loud
hope this isn't too loud I mean it's
moderately loud oh now it's good okay
[Applause]
oh look that sound okay
hey where's that one that one's the 192
let me go get this one I think I'm still
naked I'm pretty sure pretty yeah good
I'm still naked which is as life should
be there's still these bushes that I can
gather a bunch of material from let me
make more mint because they keep sucking
me dry and that's not good yeah
Thank You Zoe Evans gamer zach christian
halep dr. rainbow mitten life and Morgan
Carter mr. Nick saggy tits Phoenix mium
Kristen Bates a lot thank you all so
much
all right last try on this one if it's
all work then I'm gonna hang up my
nudist ways which is a weird turn of
phrase considering I have nothing to
hang up I want to live I want to live my
life the way I want to live it ooh maybe
oh I have an idea yes I can skill up my
stealth people will ignore my annoying
habits I can be as nude as I want to be
right that's what that that's what that
is right that's what that means I can be
super nude super duper Oh better
ointment but I want that annoyingness
gone look over there two times damage
went undetected well I don't want that
tech friendly oh well that's nice ear to
the ground but I don't have enough I'll
get that later I got to go oh yeah I do
what I gotta do I gotta do what I gotta
do and I know what I gotta do is I gotta
get over to the Faraday cage what are
the chances of mark seeing this comment
well not good if I had to say if I'm a
magic 8-ball and you're shaking me and I
had to give an out like an outcome its
outlook looks bleak all right so where
is everybody
thank you dad's where is everybody oh
there's someone
all right so if I go around and I get
just enough time they won't notice my
shiny bright buttocks oh they're gonna
notice my shiny bright buttocks quiet as
a quiet as a quiet as a mouse it's not
your thing no no I got it oh excuse me I
need to meditate for a bit after I've
done this I need to learn to forgive
myself for the horrible crime that I
just committed oh oh really
oh I'll need ointment pointman
appointment appointment appointment
buoyant good delicious ointment mmm
whoa I'm fast I'm real fast
there we go now that's what I'm talking
about see you can be nude and you can be
proud I was a weird thing you can be
nude and you can be proud and I'm proud
and I am nude see it works
he had the sound cut out it was super
that was bizarre that's not the first
time it's done that in this game either
so I don't know what the deal is but oh
well it is what it is like my little low
to the ground
I might did I grow shorter I mean I hate
that I have to explain that but did I
did I grow shorter I'm I'm mama home two
percent positive shirt and certain that
I might have actually grown shorter
there okay I can't afford to lose that
many inches off of me so okay please
please give them back whenever you feel
it's convenient for you I really need
them I need everything I can get
you're shrinking probably uh well you
know that makes sense that's what
happens when you don't take your joy its
wild uh all the bobbies are nice and
tall all right
also they're all from the exact same
family marrying into each other now
that's that's inbreeding if I ever saw
it well how do I get because this is a
big wall no here we go oh excuse me
why did I go under that what was that I
think I think like my character model is
registered as being way lower than it
should be for some reason I don't know
okay that work nevermind very broken no
know what that was yeah well 100 meters
is a lot less than what we're running
now okay no no no boy am I my brother's
keeper
I know I'm trespassing listen do I
really have to extract three beats
oh dear here we go why are you so
worried about it just grab the stuff and
go feel the breeze on your butt and
that's all all you really need
[Music]
[Music]
yeah some told me you got some guilt oh
I don't think I did terribly keen grasp
on how many unpleasant things I'll
forego wait a minute
Evan Ben was the shelter forever this is
actually gonna go down to the shelter
where Oh looks like he was trying to get
out something with him appalled what a
jolly place to go exploring oh yeah why
oh [ __ ] okay well I'm full up but I
wasn't gonna come down here anyway I
need to drop some of the shovels that I
have cuz I know I have like way too many
shovels okay let's get rid of that
g-g-gee these things can go keep the
electric truncheon I forgot about those
uh yeah but I can oh then I can I can
use these because they stun ooh
well there goes my shovels but I can
stun and that can cause a distraction so
people see mine it and my naked body
they're like ah the penis and then I zap
them and then they're like no I can't
think properly that penis really did me
a number and then they get some positive
reinforcement for it did I just steal a
memory
oh there you are mum's been worried sick
I was I was riding the subway all day
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth back
and forth until it closed well as I
supposed to pay again no you're not
supposed to run off like that without
telling anyone I was having so much fun
wouldn't let me ride no no I wouldn't
remember 1949 it was five years old we
went places on the subway with mum
before she got sick yeah well how the
times have changed huh well it's even
what's even weirder about it is like the
entirety of England seems to have regret
like that seems to be the main driving
force of why there's so much joy all
around here why they needed to take the
joy why they wanted to take the joy no
that's not that that's not the quest I'm
on I'm on the Faraday cage this one
there we go yeah so like the whole
reason behind is just is regret and it's
something to do with the kids going off
to some like probably something Bad's
probably something really really bad and
in doing so they they live with this
regret and they've all tried to forget
like their past like that's the only
thing instead of like facing it they're
just trying to push it all away as if it
never happened
hello oh you're back to normal I guess
that's good hello dr. Faraday I got your
weird mechanically bits you want them
there you go well sorry they're in a bit
of a shamble all right I don't know I
just put the thing on the thing and I
went on a thing one thing behind my butt
cheeks boots here you go yes thanks it's
my new rule that other
duh alright well there's a bed I saw a
bed I know there's a bed in here I mean
there was someone occupying the bed but
you know maybe
lovely day for it
okay all right well that's nice that's
real nice
Oh can I can I just sit here for 24
hours or do I have to go away okay come
on I just pulled a splinter out of that
Bush or that roaring fire so just I'm
tough okay I guess I just got a um oh I
saw a lightning bolt in front of me
well that's bizarre trusting uh okay
well you know it's not so bad when you
really think about it um I probably
shouldn't be in here when there's giant
bolts of electricity going everywhere
hey wait is that the pole all right what
do we got thank you for all your help
you'll go far one day which is more than
I can say for the other numpties I don't
know what they do to break the bridge
but nine times out of ten if I turn it
off and turn it back on again that does
the trick so do that you'll need to oh
okay is that really what this is all
about just going to see Sally is that
really all it is is fine linen cloths to
fight Oh steroid can I take some roids
know what I can do Connect there's some
roids I could take away hang on there's
joy here flash you still plasma joy okay
not there
no no where is it but what is what is
final oh oh it's chemical that's because
there's a chemistry set
oh it's all coming together I'm putting
two and do with two oh wow I don't know
what this does got a bad bug fino silane
can cure plague if administered early
enough oh I should probably have that on
hand I have a funny feeling I'm gonna
get the play just judging by me running
headfirst into every sort of a horrible
situations I can find naked something
tells me I'm probably gonna probably
gonna die all right
can this can this is at me the same way
it did for her no oh well can I pull
dance at least a little bit that'd be
nice mmm no okay
well there's nothing here so I got a
make up make it up to some fashion I
gotta make it up to Sally that's so sad
and pathetic is there a way that I can
fast travel somewhere okay where do I
make it up to Sally over here sir any
sort of fast traveling I can do there's
probably no fast travel right I don't
recall there being there's like track
access you can't fast travel from this
location ah but that didn't say that you
couldn't fast travel at all okay so we
got to go we got did I just slam myself
balls first spread-eagle and balls first
onto that little rock okay whatever I
don't know man my character is getting
kinkier by the second button anyway so I
don't can i fast hold from you but maybe
if I get to this hatch I can fast travel
from here so here yet visit this
location to unlock
can't fast travel by oh but I wasn't
there yet okay okay what about what
about what about this no no I I guess I
shouldn't should have gone there first
okay I gotta hoof it alright just a nice
run a simple breezy run drink some steel
it's too food or drink it's both hey
that's pretty good
or am i ik amid yen God what does that
mean what does it mean what does that
even mean what does it mean what is
wrong with you just let me live my life
I'm happy that's what this is all about
forgetting all our troubles and being
happy yeah whatever you need to take a
dump
well I mean go I guess we go go do that
I guess if you really need to go forth
thank you southern lord and thank you to
thwa smith whoa oh yeah that's where
they all are over there am i thick yes
but not in the way that you'd imagine I
am okay will they let me back into the
city if I'm completely blood a snood
mmm well downer detector oh I probably
shouldn't have gone that way um hmm can
I hop around the other side is this just
oh that's a sheer cliff okay all right
ready to behave come take your joy I
will
is there a way that I could get around
in alright fine then I can handle it
Barry look at my deck thank you a slap
on the Sally yes oh wait hang on wait no
hey please no please anything but this
don't judge my nudity Lainey top of the
mornin dear oh [ __ ] oh they don't like
it but they are laughing I can only
assume they're laughing because they're
impressed ow ow murderer
their hands are bloody you don't know
what what murder I didn't do what but
it's I swear it's very impressive
hmm okay I guess everyone's gonna be
judgmental laughing as I run naked right
across their field of vision don't laugh
you don't you don't know they did I
probably don't have blood all over me I
haven't checked but I probably don't do
I have blood on my hands the cupboard
how much blood is on me
I'm not covered in blood - how am I
covered in blood - how much blood could
I possibly be covered with never find me
all right okay am i how do I get that
off
it's probably my own blood it's my own
blood because I've been walloped so much
in my life you all haven't been walloped
I've been walloped I'm gonna get the
better medicine Body Snatcher whoo I
like that I'll go do that I like that
sneak thief mmm that's pretty good -
Arthur English runs
I can't upgrade any of those how about
do the Healy thing there we go that's
the good one oh yeah and the burden
thing that'd be good
choke out taller enemies oh I'll grow
taller I can grow taller oh boy I can't
wait for that okay no no no okay
who do you think you're wearing oh dear
you can't wear that I'm not wearing
anything
what are you all yelling at okay anyway
I'm gonna put on some clothes because I
don't think I can even progress in the
game it's a nudist stable
all right so proper clothes like a real
gentle man inventory expansion increases
weight limit before overburdened that
sounds good do I have to equip that do I
put that on my feet
use ooh
well that's handy I wish I would have
known about that okay so when he just
wait until my I gotta wait till my
withdrawal wears off and then it's gonna
be okay then I can go so I put clothes
back on
naked markiplier is now dead are you all
happy but as soon as I get over to Sally
I'm taking all my clothes off as fast as
I possibly can okay here we go ah there
we go withdrawal overloaded a nice
Bobby's hey you want some booze yeah you
want some booze BLAP BLAP oh you're good
you're good you're good all right
constant constable Rosa get a lot of
things in this line of duty
you're welcome a constable Rizzoli
it'll be much better talking here when
you're completely slammed there we go
once more just want you to know that I
appreciate what you do another another
bottle what's the hopper there you go
pretty good right about one more for the
road there you go yeah we're all good
habits here good habits customed
such generosity
populace you're welcome buddy you're
welcome friend I can't talk to you
anymore
I can't like it I can't talk to him
anymore
Oh over oh you all right there you go I
can't hey you don't mind if I you don't
mind if I just excuse me don't mind me
don't mock me I'm just near your
buttocks doing something very totally
legal excuse me pardon me
put clothes there all right turn it off
I'll put the code doo buh doo buh Boop
good there whole room do I turn it back
on
all right all better I guess okay so I
gotta do another downer no no no listen
I'm fine look at me I just needed it
take my pill go to the book book little
bit of Boop
Oh Magda finally little defeat the
purpose over Lily
ba-dum bum bum ba Pettifer goddamnit
baba daddy put a little whoopee there we
go
Oh God oh I got it I can okay I did it I
don't know what would happen if I got
spanked let me put on my gas mask cuz I
don't want no more joy I can yeah I can
yeah I I know yeah I know
now Simon Says step on three leap
platforms
okay boop boop ass getting so cold in my
office asking so cold it's getting
ridiculously cold it's getting cold
I've talked about before but the
air-conditioner in this office is way
too good oh god it's okay you got it
buddy what the hell man I'm trying good
god I was trying man oh how much faster
grab God bridge and then I'm in the
parade
I want more bridge after that wails okay
all right then well though you can't be
mad at my antics I'm such a playful soul
wallowy willowy well
well the Louisville okay but I'm gonna
run it I'm gonna turn into withdrawal
real soon here so I got to find a place
to kind of stay away from everybody once
I get over here is there a repeat oh
it's gonna it's gonna be closed here
Thank You Nikki V MLP okay what's back
here maybe I can tuck away for a little
bit
morning it's past curfew it's past what
it's past curfew why is it past curfew
no shoot okay hang on I'm almost there
I'm just gonna gun it cuz I think I can
make it zero way back here maybe
no I goddamn it okay well I'm down I'm
really with rudy' Road but I think I can
still just sneak over there cuz I have
to sneak anyway and now's the perfect
time to take off my clothes
no one can sneak as well as I can when
I'm new did
so sneaky no one ever knew
no one ever know who did no one ever
knowed no one ever did know I you didn't
hear anything did you okay I'm close
oh god it's so cold I'm getting like a
blast of frigid air right on my noggin
oh so cold
why is it so cold Oh gas mask please I
thought doesn't count as clothes does it
oh my god oh it's so cold
I am dying oh it's so cold
oh my god it's so cold
oh but it's a better problem than if it
wasn't cold so I'm fine okay um hi can I
get in through this way or not harbors
unsure but considering this looks like
it's almost boarded up I'm gonna assume
that this is oh [ __ ] oh oh that's a cop
do hide you don't know that I'll just
stick my head sticking up perfectly
normal like who don't say what is that
what the hell is wrong with you what did
you just do whoa oh I'm better now what
did you just do
take it off the gas bus I'm gonna sniffs
nothing was that boy okay let's see if I
can climb up this thing oh okay I gotta
get up here no it's nothing
no no no no it's fine look look it's
fine nothing see totally fine all right
so goddamnit really really really really
okay Sally [ __ ] this up
we need a letter of transit and an old
friend don't [ __ ] this up Oh Sally Sally
so Sally ho awesome have a go at me
again I used to think about what I'd say
if I ever ran into you again but being a
complete ass was sort of improvising
there look this is not a spectacular
time you said you know general Bing yeah
he's a client a pharmaceutical client I
haven't had sex with anyone in ten years
and if I did he wouldn't be with that
man that's a weird thing just to say did
you really come here for letter of
transit well did you just need an excuse
well I sort of do need the letter of
transit I am Megan Hoffa if you're
really gonna do something spectacularly
stupid these might come in handy no
thanks they make your pupils that teeny
tiny just like Joey does but they have
fun you know effect about the letter
could you do something for me
of course what I need a bottle of cod
liver oil
I'd really like one cod liver oil what
you want cod liver oil like your mum
used to torment you with I wish I could
remember her
you know how Joey [ __ ] up your memories
why why would you want to remember if
it's too much to ask but always kind of
hoping for absolutely I will ask my
friend the general for our rotten scrap
of paper just for old times sake oh I'm
being an arse again aren't I I'll get it
for you though letter
I'm not crazy but I am always a little
extra competence we used to understand
oh I'll get it for you I mean Oh Troy
you are always the best of the lot I've
missed you so yeah I really should go
you don't have to I really really have
to Elsa
what what no no I don't have to actually
I am Michael schedule just cleared its
curfew it okay oh say cod liver oil
dr. fellow custom at the labs on earth
glass keeps the whole private stash of
rare ingredients
I'm sort of persona non grata there you
see I'm the competition don't be careful
[Music]
we're what the hell man well hell man
all the signals were blaring why did
Sally kiss me why it's not possible that
she really wants me is it because that
is a consummation devoutly to be wish'd
and when you want something that much
you tend to miss the signs that you have
lost all touch with reality but for one
shining moment I was a hero at the end
of the movie and I got the girl then I
pulled away why did you pull because I
was plummeting to earth and I had to
grab a parachute I told her I was there
about letter transmitted back to into
the city she thought I was just there to
see her again which one is true I've
been lying to myself about so many
things oh my god it's just a bunch of
excuses that I've had laughter laughter
laughs laughs but my god I walked in
there naked like I was just brimming
with confidence confidence shooting out
of every part of me she was so into it I
got a kiss she was like uh yeah and it
was like could have smashed what the
hell are thir was wrong with you she's a
gent at sex in ten years
that's a hell of a dry spell and you're
swooped in there oh man look dude Arthur
Arthur come on man Arthur come on cod
liver oil cod liver oil all right before
the great lips debacle I managed to
bring up her mum brilliant
she misses dear old mum the woman tried
to poison her and did in her entire
[ __ ] family why did I tell her I'd
get her cod liver oil because she can
get a letter of transit and because I
can never say no to Sally I can say no
to a container under Percy but not Sally
wine dog's name can I never say no to
Sally look all right admittedly it's
probably not the bet
jammed maybe I need to lube up first
with some hailing balm I'm rubbing it on
my nip knob Sally
all right admittedly this has this only
as much as that had like green flags up
there also a lot of red flags a lot of
red flags going up there too so
you know the old adage never stick your
dick and crazy there's there's a few
lessons to be learned about that like
I'm not bald and of that phrase itself
but sometimes you got to learn if she's
trying to get something that's gonna
remind her of her mom that her mom
poisoned her old family and tried to
poison her that's a few red flags that's
a few red flags so maybe it's for the
best but at the end of the day I got all
naked and lubed up for nothing do I have
I thought I had lockpicks don't I have
lock picks
where's my lock picks outfits lock pick
no I'm not a bobby pins well god damn it
one available in mint wait do I have a
lock pick the keys no lock pick I only
have one of the bobby boots and that's
it okay
well [ __ ] alright I'll have to come back
for that later anyway
hello someone out here I'm naked and on
the balcony look at me look at me yeah
okay excuse me yeah yeah I'm sure AM
wait shouldn't I use the UH
shouldn't I use that thing that she gave
me the the whatchamacallit the wood the
thing that made my eyes go all big she
it was like a little rocket ship I don't
know what that was all about no didn't
she
I thought she did she gave me something
and I can never find what it is yeah
whatever
it's probably fine okay I'm just gonna
gun it over there
excuse me Oh guilty come on come on
guilty okay
he that believeth not less and less and
less and less
you guys are panicking over a whole lot
of nothing hey hey come on hey come on
what where am I going help oh okay I see
right there look at his butt cheeks go
oh he's got a great board on that one
very lubed up boy I didn't know you were
nice before anyway you think that they
would get like some pictures of me as I
go by and maybe remember me for the next
time that I come sprinting through naked
times doing
Izu done it I mean no probably not but
it seems to be working out for me so
ain't gonna complain too much man I wish
I had like a vehicle or something some
kind of a moped or like a scooty do or
something like that at least give me a
skateboard so I can do some city tricks
I sure won't have done it whoa oh wow
that that what is that maybe that's
something that's some real special
what is that what is that that's so
weird
why hey listen I'm you guys gotta give
it up like I got some booze if you what
is this what is what the hell I'm going
down here for cod liver oil I'll just go
grab a cod out of the ocean and squeeze
it why do I need to go into this
horrible Hell labs this is the most evil
looking thing I've ever seen in my life
I've never seen anything more evil than
this building in with lab since Harry
Hayworth get that big tour a few years
ago I'm a reporter I'm supposed to
interview dr. bilac I hope he hasn't
forgotten the office so a press pass
gets me in amazing what people do to get
in the newspaper maybe I can go talk to
mrs. on a fan to the okuru see if she's
got a spare press posh
well that is a long way to go huh is
there some other thing I can do that's a
lot of chemicals well where's the ogre
ah how do I get to the ocher all where's
the ogre all is it over there
good god now I have to run all the way
back over the bridge
I wonder if it'd be faster just to jump
off and die the old Quran is where I
first came from so be funny to complete
okay
please blind an uncle Pat Gekko
I have a pet gecko I have no idea though
I'm thinking that if I resurrect it's
gonna be faster anyway it's up for
whatever you write we write for the
nudist nationals
oh god damn it I'm still here all right
whatever
enter labs but I I don't have the Press
Pass Oh oh god I gotta listen to this
again so a press post gets me arrogant
people no no I gotta go Smee there we go
okay gotta go to get in the newspaper
he's Oliphant at the okuru see if she's
gonna spare Chris Paul and I don't have
anything that I can like fast travel
over there too so I gotta go like over
here here and then yeah all right I
guess I gotta go running again naked
through the entire city once more some
tea you'll get you there to finger up
alright come on there we go that's a
little pep here
that's a peppier step here alright yeah
it is all the way over there um don't
mind me butt-ass naked still regretting
my interaction with sally for some
reason every time that I get near her I
keep messing it all up over and over
again
can't survive this without a suit my
dude I'm doing just fine thank you very
much I am doing wonderfully and
everything's great so maybe you're wrong
and I'm doing this game right you know
maybe I'm maybe I'm winning it see I'm
sneaky I've got that special perk you
can't even scan me oh I don't wonder if
I can even get in from like this side
that I'm going now probably not it's
probably not like an entrance in here
maybe this is oh no no it's a solid wall
of building oh that's pathetic where's
my grappling hook Oh No I goofed it
didn't I oh I goofed it did I goof it
hard I've goofed it haven't I
oh I've super goofed it oh I've goofed
it so good oh I've goofed it oh my god
goofed it oh my goo feed it no no
there's nothing here
oh I goofed it so good oh god I goofed
it completely I'm oh god I've goofed it
ah man I'm just a big goof bollocks
flapping in the wind buttcheeks
nothing it's no bit boy yeah oh wait
maybe this isn't in this isn't in please
tell me it's an in know this is just an
elegantly designed exterior oh god I
goofed it oh I goofed it I'm in the one
area that I can't oh my god I goofed it
fool on me for thinking that I could go
on the outside and actually get
somewhere about this fool on me fool on
me Oh fool me fool me once ah boy drink
some more tea oh boy fool me I should
have actually have turned around and go
around it's like when I was playing pub
G zombies and like I just keep running
and I'm like this is wrong and it feels
wrong you'd be quicker to go back and I
can't get in the circle in time and
everything
horrible oh my goodness gracious oh god
well now that I've got a good lay of the
less here here there's an in here wise
urn in here right right
oh my god oh well that looks pretty
deadly but hey I'm pretty deadly do you
think I get better at running if I was
running this much how about in here in
here no that's wrong
ha I'm sorry listen it's fine there's
got to be like a trash can I can hide in
somewhere around here right here no hide
yeah I mean I'm not really near enough
to hide but that's 39 meters away it's
right around the corner okay that should
be fine don't know about oh why they do
both oh that is though dude I didn't
really well well anyone love you
like man it should be it will be good to
see all my old co-workers again I'm sure
they'll be happy to see me okay let me
see if that's good enough okay I just
got a sneak sneak a little no no no no
oh no no no I was all right there and
all face no don't sit don't sit down
don't don't sit down what are you doing
what are you miss what caused an arc
close close close it close it are
supposed to get upstairs then um anyway
Sarah wait sunshine is that what it is
oh boy
I think that is this what it's oh yeah
yeah yeah it's victoy
hey how you doing okay okay love a
sneaking suspicion that they want some
coffee no sneaking suspicion huh um I'm
not a hundred do you think someone could
let me upstairs
can't you see I'm coffee okay called me
pop me do you think someone could let me
upstairs if you don't stop history me
I'll murder someone I swear I will
I didn't do that I didn't I'm not doing
that what is doing that what's doing
there me of me do you think someone
could let me upstairs unless it's the
second coming I can't be bothered
[Music]
okay um I don't have a lock pick hello
how are you
no one seems to be bothered by the fact
that I am completely nude
oh here's the Power Cell okay well this
is pretty easy all right for fire
requires four coffee beans do I really
is this what I have to do is this is
this my life is this is this my life yep
here we go
okay you all right I think I've broken
the game pretty considerably have some
scotch you want some this for you drink
it right through your gas mask I can't
wait to see this slow okay me flirt is
it because I'm naked me too
yes I am yes I am can someone let me
upstairs please can someone please let
me upstairs so I'm gonna let me upstairs
mrs. tingles lily-livered delight I
don't want to know what that is can can
someone
I don't bobby pin oh no what's happening
oh there we go
does that eat alright just that easy
well I can get me Susana fen to get me
my old job back am i old press pause
yeah just that easy huh I guess you know
I guess why why should I doubt it so
much if it makes sense like all they
want is for people to take their joy
right like that's that's been the end
result of all of this you just need to
take your joy and then you're welcome
back into society forget all your
troubles you're not a downer anymore eat
your rat and everything will be right as
rain raw it is range there we go what's
up there better rub some healing balm on
me for good luck and don't need it hey
hey boss hey that's me hasn't it where
did you go when you disappeared for two
weeks
did you ever remember must have had two
lovely a time I was hoping you could use
a reporter I'm afraid I've got two half
dozen of them bloody useless the lot of
them I've got six pieces on my desk all
about the new flavour of joy
can you imagine it's coconut didn't
talked of lot make that announcement
sometime ago Gemma wanted to do a piece
on him I hope she hasn't fallen in a
hole or somewhere they haven't seen her
in days
it's bloody frustrating too there's all
sorts of silly rumors about the tunnels
under Wellington wells gas leaks water
main breaks maintenance workers at the
pub instead of their posts
that were all true Wellington Wells
would be about to fall apart I asked her
to do a story about it I'm sure she'll
turn up and everything will be pitching
BJ I'm sure it will lovely to see you
Arthur
drop by anytime I will
especially when I'm nude Emma was always
digging up interesting stuff from what I
remember man where are they sending her
grant that days I just keep getting
tossed around all these same places I'm
kind of curious as why cuz there's got
to be like May it's it's it's not
contrived back and forth miss like I'm
not I'm not criticising for that but at
the same time it's like like why am I
being tossed around so frequently when I
could be doing something else I don't
know oh no where no point in complaining
about it I doubt there's anything secret
in here but I'm just checking just to be
sure
hai-yah wing oh shoot
speedrunning tactics okay where can I go
is it downstairs also the frame rate
seems to have taken a dump lately and I
don't know why hello down here maybe
here or oh gosh you're dropping on Jemma
a hug if she's really vanished then
maybe I can get my old job back
huh I think it'd be funny I have
artistic hobbies over there chopping the
boilers who said that I'm molding leeks
down there whining okay
waiting for your piece huh well now I
gotta find her house oh boy ah manna
just a so much back and forth oh but I
didn't find anything over there to act
Oh God
alright alright alright I'll go over to
Jamie's house oh it's still curfew
god damnit ah popped out for some good
coffee
okay well nothing to be done about it
just got a run for it screaming naked
topham alongs all that stuff raw meat
rod mushroom scotch blue quran Ron
potato mushroom honey honey will that
help me like Chuck some money down
didn't seem to help all right excuse me
pardon me pardon me excuse me I need to
go somewhere I've got places to be
things do people to see um this way I
guess guilty guilty you don't know about
that good thing these guys are just out
of shape as I am or else I'd have a
problem there punch my buttcheeks
I can't clench my buttcheeks any harder
than I'm clenching him right now Oh
flash makes you run faster let's try it
yes please
everybody known about this I would have
been taking a lot more long time ago
holy crap doo doo doo doo oh that's oh
that's much better
oh that's that's much better oh that's
that's mucho better oh I love that
say something funny please well there
you go when I said it do one we blow
Leland excuse me sorry you missed me oh
wait where am I oh damn it
well time to make a loop I guess oh damn
it damn it damn it damn well that's an
excuse to to like go to more chemistry
sets and cook up more of that because
with the amount of running that you do
in this game cuz it seems very obvious
that you'd need it all right well I
gotta go over one more damn these
confusing streets and pop in another
bill well that's the last of my flash
and up this way and oh my mate boy
that's a lot of you guys how do they
have so many twins are you oldest cloned
so Wallace so own that's so own I see
okay so it's just on the other side here
it's actually good this way I don't
bother me now and I'm too fast for you
what is that huh I hate it oh my god I
hate it oh my god I hate it oh god it's
coming from Jimmy's house oh my god oh
[ __ ]
oh well that way oh hey what the [ __ ] is
someone notice she's not been around and
decided to rob the place
okay what's in the waste bin
okay all right hey I'm good okay
Oh only one toy trade and your swag bag
I'm gonna knock you lost tooth Dania
front kudos tuna [ __ ] finger come
back down here right now if the alarms
upstairs I'm gonna have to get past mr.
shelter here well that's easy enough
oh okay goodbye what the what what what
oh um oh okay
I'm very confused I think there was a
zappy upstairs and he just walked
straight into it
well that was dumb for him okay all
right cool so I need to kill the alarm
where is the alarm it's upstairs but I'm
not gonna be able to get to that because
he just died from going there so all
right maybe I can maybe I'll be fine
I'll run past it probably okay come in
oh listen
that's not nice wait where's my rubber
suit I got to put on my rubber suit for
this one this is what this is for and
this turns it all into something very
pleasurable I don't know why those those
are radioactive and like doing that
yeah I got the cat suit on it's all good
feel better now let's see sleep hide
search medical bomb okay this is a nice
place real nice real nice blaze there's
something else wait I saw something else
note there weird I haven't been reading
my notes but okay turn that off a few
dice someday yeah bleach I'll take that
wash my eyes out a bit this this steel
Kerikeri stale stale stale stale clothes
privacy while I steal steal steal docked
a bobby pin steel ok good and some music
hello
hello you have no right to touch me you
know perfectly well I've taken my joy
you can't take me away I'm not sick
where are they taking her why did they
take her what she sounds quite sane did
she know too much well how do I get down
there and how do I get down there and
help her should not go [ __ ] Oh should we
just take everything I don't think dr. V
would like that the Constabulary might
notice I don't see anything talking
about dr. B here where's our study I
thought vampires have to be invited in
don't well just have to get a little
sass in there oh okay let me some time
yeah but you didn't even need to you
didn't need to announce yourself to them
oh there's nothing in here all right
whatever okay
uh step there step there teacup take
that I don't know what I'm doing with
all the [ __ ] that I gather
I mean I've gathered so much crap that I
just don't even understand what the
point of it all is n right to lift the
locks looking for a permanent solution
ah well that's not a minute if I
finished Gemma's investigations missus
Oliphant would have to give me back my
old job and then I'd have a press post
oh boy see this is this a really
roundabout way to get into a building
you've been a busy girl haven't you
Gemma
there could have been something a lot
more simple about this it'd just be like
oh god now I got everything finished she
found all the answers yet I got to
finish her investigation in order to be
able to get out of here that is
hilarious
hi larious oh where am I now
she had a greenhouse man for a reporter
she seemed kind of loaded this is a nice
place
alright let's see if I can make up some
more flash oh no this is just a this is
a workbench I don't think I can make
anything here black powder I don't even
know if I'd want to make that anyway let
me make more lockpicks at least i mean a
lot of those short spike what do you
need for that whew
that seems good I'll do that torch on I
need that repair kit probably I don't
know what this is for okay hmm
one more of these and then a couple more
of these and then one more lockpick
water filter okay
and then one one more block fit okay
that's pretty good for that medicated
bomb that's so nice
I'll do that more okay and that's good
and then I should probably do this just
because I I do get I do get seen a lot
at night when I'm very naked and I do
tend to go out a lot at nice whoa ow
what the Frick man
oh god this thing Oh God all right so
what am i doing for the investigation I
sing the body electric go to the work
site and what is this thing what is this
thing
why-why-why [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
you're horrifying it what are you oh my
god that's just terrifying I don't know
what I'm doing what what is the point of
it uh what is what's the point of that
well jeez
whoa hang on
would you do what's happening here Oh
what is this what is the point of this I
don't even know I'm out of here
I matter here baby uh yeah that's so
weird
it's so weird what is that horrible
everything in this city is horrible
everything in this entire place is a
horrible it's all horrible why is it all
here I'm going the wrong way
oh my god that's right I'll listen hey
listen listen listen listen buddy listen
buddy listen buddy pal buddy pal buddy
pal buddy pal look you uh oh [ __ ] I
thought no no no no no no listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen
okay there's got to be like a trash can
I can sneak in at some point here
yeah maybe not doesn't seem to be very
kind to me I'm not I'm not coming with
you I'm not doing that at all no all
right which way am I going okay so it
should be two right
excuse me sorry I can't believe I lost
the other ones somehow in here oh hi so
clear off okay
well so I need a boiler suit is that
that all I need they're really all I
need you kidding me do we now that's so
funny
that's so funny that you'd say that well
I think we do we're the same size
I think we are hang on wait hang on I
gotta wait for him to fall down I'm
gonna get his stuff and did I get wait I
didn't get his clothes hold my balls
where'd you punch me right in the dick
all right well that didn't work
so take key by any means necessary
ow oh god I don't have the key all right
listen you guys about to get zip zapped
I got you oh oh god I'm dead
there you go flap flap flap was
problematic thought there we go okay all
right so that is about as final as I can
make it and I am going to end this one
here I knew I was gonna be able to get
it but it's just so funny I was bouncing
me around like this it just seems like
very contrived at the moment and it's
it's like the game is fun and all but
also it's just like a lot of back and
forth and it's just like a reason to see
this city that they built and not
necessarily a reason to just like I
don't know exist in it you know what I
mean but that'll do it for now I'm still
having fun with it so thank you
everybody so much for or you engage
interaction can't price can save that's
why fine yeah so thank you everybody so
much for watching take care and if you
thank you everybody that joined the
channel through memberships thank you
everybody the game through super chat
even though you didn't need to and thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the other videos if you want to see
anything else that I've done there's
more parts that we happy few if you
haven't seen them there's more videos on
the way and other cool stuff coming and
then I will be leaving for Korea next
week and then I will be out making
videos on occasion over there but most
of the time I'll be spending time with
my family so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye guys
bye bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you